dans ce film on vous découvre un peu
cleptomane cette c'est un rôle que vous
connaissez dans la vie qu'est-ce qui
inspirait le premier c'était l'idée de
départ ou c'est pendant que vous
tourniez tout d'un coup vous avez déjà
parlé avec Claude Lelouch il s'adapte à
la personnalité des gens pour qu'on se
sente bien dans le rôle pour qu'on se
sente bien dans qu'est-ce que vous
voulez me faire dire là au lieu
d'essayer de tourner autour du pot dit
franchement ce que vous mettez
zone non pas du tout c'était très
agréable
et vous est-ce que vous regrettez
certaines lettres que vous m'avez envoyé
que jamais je vous en aurai parlé si
vous m'aviez pas posé cette question
alors qu'on vous avait demandé avant de
vous taire comme vous n'avez pas de
parole je n'aime pas me taire et d'abord
vous me l'ayez pas demandé avant
pourquoi est-ce que vous ne m'évoquez
pas cette histoire pourquoi est-ce que
ça parce que je suis venu pour parler du
film de Claude lelouze qu'est-ce que
vous venez faire là la merde et
faire de la provocation gratuite mais
c'est une chose qui vous a touché je
vais vous demander